[Music]
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on microbial
testing for the pharmaceutical industry
a straightforward path towards
regulatory compliance data integrity and
computer system validation by darrell
leone and sandy true
i'm ben haywin of thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be moderating
today's event
before we begin i'd like to encourage
you to engage with us you can submit as
many questions as you want at any time
you want during the presentation
simply type them into the ask a question
box on the left and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of this
presentation
you can also join us for our ask the
expert sessions right after this event
please welcome daryl and sandy
thank you van
hello everyone my name is daryl leon and
i'm a senior product manager in farm
analytics at thermo fisher scientific
today sandy and i can discuss how thermo
fisher scientific can enable you to
comply
to the computer systems validations
for microbial testing in your bio
production workflow
in our presentation today we will cover
three main areas
that may be of interest to anyone
needing to comply with microbial
identification requirements
of their local governmental agency
first we will provide an overview of the
regulatory guidance around validation
specifically related to microbial
identification in a gmp
environment
second
we will share our real world examples of
how some customers had to learn the hard
way
what not to do when trying to meet
regulatory compliance when dealing with
computer systems validation
and finally we will review how thermo
fisher scientific can provide you a
complete microbial identification system
and solution to meet your data integrity
requirements
for overall pharma applications
we have industry leading capabilities
across
the entire bioprocessing workflow
we provide integrated solutions across
bioprocessing workflows from
pre-clinical through commercial
manufacturing
there are two main ways
we provide safety and quality
dna sequencing and real-time pcr
technologies
specifically we provide high-throughput
highly specific analytical solutions for
microplasma detection
residual dna
and virus detection
with real-time pcr
and with our dna sequencing technology
we enable you to do microbial
identification
of bacterial and fungal organisms
due to the possible harmful effects of
microorganisms
regulatory agencies expect
pharmaceutical organizations to have an
environmental monitoring program as part
of good manufacturing practices
it is also recommended to identify
microorganisms at the species level
at frequent intervals
to establish a valid
current database of contaminants
present in a facility
after choosing the id technology to be
implemented the system needs to be
validated and verified
usp
1113 describes the recommendation
for verification of id method
specifically the usp monograph
recommended to include one of the
following tests
use an existing system to do
comparability tests of isolates from
routine testing
the number of isops can be as high as 50
or
testing
by the use of let's say 12 to 15
reference stock cultures of different
commonly isolated species
or
confirming
20 to 50 organisms
that get id'd which includes 50 to 20
species with a reference lab
it is important to note that the
parameters used to verify the methods
are accurate and reproducible
how the data records are maintained can
be based on four main characteristics
these include reliability
accuracy
usability
integrity
because data integrity is so important
what is data integrity
it is really comprised of several topics
first there is the focus on the accuracy
of data being generated and it
next
how the data is being recorded and
stored
and finally
data integrity should be managed and
processed
based on good documentation practices
now there are three main ways to achieve
compliant data integrity through csv
first
you can choose to work with a third
party consultant
but you will need to consider their
experience with regulatory requirements
and quality
second you may rely on internal company
resources but they may lack the
experience with the microseek id system
and finally you can rely on thermofisher
scientific to have the experience
of your microseek id system and
knowledge of regulatory concerns to
assist you with your validation
expand on this topic allow me to
introduce my colleague sandy true
she has many years of experience in the
field working with customers just like
you
and hearing about their challenges with
computer systems validation
for microbial identification
thanks daryl as you noted i've had many
years experience helping customers with
their computer system validation
as they implement environmental
monitoring for microbial pathogen
identification
as a staff scientist with our field
application group
it's my honor to assist customers in
this process
and what i'd like to do today is to go
through a couple examples of real world
experiences where customers have used
either third party
groups to help with their computer
system validation or they've used
internal resources to go through this
and to explain how both of these
situations have resulted in different
experiences for the customer and the
ways that thermo fisher has been able to
assist them in both
so what i'd like to start with here
is
the example of
a customer that i worked with in years
past that used a third party contractor
for their csv
in this situation the customer chose to
use a third-party contractor because
they had multiple sites across north
america where they were implementing
the csv at each of these sites
but in each of these cases the
contractor was in control of the
installation and access to the
microseekid system
and the contractor didn't have any
training on our system at all
so the users of the system were forced
to take training before the contractor
had finished their validation process
and then the system was not enabled and
not put into use before the validation
was complete
so the users were left without a system
that they could use but had been trained
on
now
when this happened the contractor set
out a number of worst case scenarios and
this is pretty typical in any
csv situation
they're looking to test the system to
make sure that they enable it to pass
any risk that might take place
so
this ended up resulting in software
conflicts and errors
because the contractor didn't know the
capabilities of our microseek id
software
and
this resulted in the contractor needing
to come back to thermo fisher in order
to seek resolution for these errors
so this resulted in
a lot of time and support being spent
not only on my
time but also on the part of our
engineering team to go in and to
actually repair some of the errors that
were taking place and were set up by the
use of the contractor setting out these
worst case scenarios
in the end
system validation took well over 18
months from the time the system was
installed until the time the actual
users could start using it for their
microbial identification
there were repeated software conflicts
and errors and these took long
resolution times because the contractor
tried to solve them themselves before
they came to me for support
then the users had to purchase an
additional training and this ended up
costing them time and money because they
had been trained too early in the
process
but the biggest cost then to the user
actually ended up being money that they
spent having to outsource testing
because it spent so long in the
validation process they actually weren't
able to get their system up and running
very quickly and they had to outsource
this environmental testing to others and
that cost them a lot of money
so this is the difficulty they had in
working with a third party contractor
and this wasn't unusual not for this
site and not for other sites where they
implemented this particular process
but i'd like to explain a second
situation that we had and this was for a
customer that used their own internal
resources
because some of our smaller size
customers will take and they'll use
their internal i.t
resources in order to save money they
don't have the money to go to an outside
third party contractor so they take what
resources they have internally and they
use them to implement their computer
system validation because their internal
resources know their computer systems
and can network things to meet their
internal needs
the difficulty that we have here is that
internal i.t departments being
responsible for data integration and
data storage they're responsible for all
the computer systems across their entire
company
so they're not specialists
and they aren't aware of risks that need
to be based on specific technologies and
specific processes
they again
don't know the microseek id system they
can't be experts on everything
so in this case one size doesn't fit all
and unfortunately for this particular
customer
when the fda came in and audited their
facility on their regular annual basis
they found that there were data
integrity and data security risks that
were unique to the microseek id system
in this case it was the ability to
delete and to alter data and this is a
huge risk within a gmp facility
data backup was not compliant and secure
with current federal regulations under
the fda and there were individual user
logins that also weren't compliant
and this resulted in an fda finding it
their audit
this puts the customer at great risk
when you're under an fda finding
now you're under a timeline in order to
get this fixed the fda is going to put
you under additional scrutiny until they
see that you've resolved this issue
the company
came to us in this case
they sought manufacturer validation
support
and what this allowed them to do then
was minimize their system downtime
so that they could get back up and
running
and realize computer system validation
that would put them
back in a compliant state for their fda
so this allowed them also to minimize
additional dollar spending of sending
out samples because while their system
was undergoing their validation they did
have to take it offline internally and
they did have to send samples out to
another site in order to be
analyzed
so
this
realized a temporary increase in their
turnaround time while these samples were
being sent out but it was minimized
compared to what it might have been had
they tried to fix it on their own
so these two scenarios here show you
what can happen when customers try to
either take a third-party contractor or
do it on their own
but what they don't realize sometimes is
that thermo fisher offers one source for
a seamless implementation toward
regulatory compliance
and we've developed this for our
microseek identification solution
so we bring in the technology and
support starting with the purchase of
the system our customer buys an
instrument but they also buy the
consulting service
we go through the installation and the
training
this timeline depends on the customer's
availability
if the customer needs things to move
more rapidly
we can mobilize our resources to meet
that kind of timeline for them
then we move into our computer system
validation phase
now yes it can take 10 to 12 weeks from
start to completion but again this can
depend on customer availability
but we offer them complete project
management documentation and approvals
we offer them validation test execution
and customer approvals
we have
computer system
validation specialists to execute these
test plans and to give this information
to the customer
so that when the customer has
implementation of their system they've
been covered from the beginning to the
end
what it really comes down to for us
is this entire msid implementation
program
where we put the customer at the heart
of everything we do
and so it's a holistic approach and as a
field application scientist we're just
part of this circle that is going to
be for the customer
so we have detailed training that's
there
not just on the assay that comes into
play for the bacterial and fungal
identification
but we have implementation guidance
everything that starts with
setting up the lab according to your
good manufacturing process and your good
laboratory and molecular biology
practices
but
a checklist of implementation materials
that would be required we have
introductions to the basics of the dna
based
sequencing and traditional culture
methods
we have validation guidance that we're
going to give to the customer that helps
them plan out how they're going to put
their system into a validated state
we have organizations
and methods that we can teach the
customers so that they can handle
everything from low throughput to high
throughput
and we have user group workshops where
we keep the customer in touch with
long-term training
because part of our implementation
program
is being with the customer from the very
first time they contact us about a sale
through the very last time they need to
contact us for support
our support doesn't end
we're there for software training we're
there for analysis from data collection
through identification
we talk with them about what good
acceptance criteria is an interpretation
of the sequencing id results we talk
with them about routine system
maintenance so that they know the best
practices of their instrument and of
their software
we talk with them about data archiving
and we talk with them about recommended
performance qualifications and that's
all before we get to the computer system
validation
so
darryl
really our entire program is about
making the customer successful
and that's really what i want to
get across to everyone
but
what else do we have in microsec
and microbial testing that you can tell
the customer about
thanks sandy i appreciate the those user
stories and and i agree there are other
things that we you know need to consider
for a microbial identification system
so in choosing which identification
method or technology to adopt there are
really three main parameters to consider
uh these three main factors to consider
are
data quality
which is essential for any regulated
laboratory environment
um there's technology which is thinking
about time to results and thinking about
throughput
and i guess like everyone is is about
cost
basically looking into return on
investment
you know should you do
should you id in-house or or should you
outsource so these are the
considerations that that one must have
now in terms of
microbial identification
microseq id in particular is a genotypic
method
based on on the sequence analysis of
ribosomal genes in bacteria and fungi
the microsquid method is a
well-established
genotypic system that has been adopted
by 23 of the top 25 pharmaceutical
organizations globally
and
20 out of the top 25 pharmaceuticals
have multi-site adoption
so the genetic sequencing has been
considered really as the gold standard
for phylogenetic classification of
bacteria and fungi and has been designed
to support the recommended qualification
guidances
now the microseek id system is a high
throughput comparative dna sequencing
for identification of bacteria
fungi and yeast
and you know the whole system includes
the
pcr and sequencing kits
genetic analyzers or sequencer
and the microsequid software and the
associated libraries
and the pcr thermocycler
so you know one of the
uh the solutions is is the system
and uh
and what it is is that one of one
example here is the 3500 3500 xl genetic
analyzer which is really an excellent
choice for high throughput labs
showing up on uh shown on the on the
lower side
if you're more if you want a more easy
to use lower throughput system this is
something you'd use for smaller labs
and we've got you covered as well
this system uses the seek studio genetic
analyzer and use the same kits and
software as the high throughput system
that's shown that's shown below
now the microseek id system allows you
to either um
use current species libraries or you
know what you can actually build your
own library if you want
in either configuration the system
allows you to choose the right library
for your microbial identification
projects
and in addition
the software provides you within
sae compliant reports
auto analysis from sequencing to final
reports
now our csv service can assist you when
you're preparing for validation as well
we can provide a dedicated staff we have
knowledge of validation as you as you
heard earlier from from sandy
documentation
fae
and specifically we can bring you know
really a dedicated project management
experience
validation specialist as mentioned
earlier
se software workflow
and basically we have a lot of
experience specialists
now why choose us well
we can really provide complete
transparency to facilitate regulatory
compliance that's something we can stand
behind is term future scientific
we have an integrated support team
of highly experienced specialists
and our teams are flexible really as
sandy mentioned to really meet your
timeline and your business requirements
and and finally you are supported by a
whole range
of demofisher scientific colleagues
who can provide the answers you need to
move forward in compliance
simply put you know we can save you time
money and compliance headaches before
because we can provide you the
experience and and
expertise to meet your microbial
identification goals
obviously within a regulatory compliance
environment
in terms of computer system validation
we can provide you up to 12 separate
components related to consulting
services or documentation to help you
achieve or maintain
your compliance requirements
for example we can provide you a
validation plan
test plans
installation qualifications
quality assurance
all types of things
but to really illustrate how we can do
this i'm going to bring sandy back and
she and she can discuss how thermo
fisher scientific
has helped the customer with their csv
requirements
thanks daryl
you know i love what you said earlier
about
having a team there to support the
customer
because this next
customer illustration
really demonstrates how our teams can
come together to give the customer the
best csv experience possible
this was a really unique situation that
we had
a long time customer came to us
and asked us to implement a csv for them
and they gave us a timeline they said we
need a csv completed in six weeks
so
when they met six weeks they meant six
weeks turnaround time and that meant
from the time the instrument was
installed until the time it was up and
running and validated for use
six weeks complete and the new system
had to be identical to a current system
they had in place in their laboratory
but this would also include updating and
expanding their current microbial
identification libraries
and we would also then have to follow on
very quickly by updating their current
system with those new microbial
identification libraries
so this is going to take a team if we
were going to execute this in the
timeline that the customer needed so
this required coordination of all of our
specialists our technical sales
specialists tss our field service
engineers fse
of course myself the fas and our
compliance team we all had to get
together and so we had coordinated phone
conference calls with the customer and
without the customer every week we took
pre-loaded documents we took the
documents that you just went through in
your last slide darrell and we used the
ones that had been completed for the
previous instrument that we loaded for
the customer
and set those up for the new system we
prepared a specialized plan for how we
could validate the new library for the
customer
and then we put together the tightest
schedule we possibly could
and the beauty of it all was that by
coordinating this team of specialists
across the company
we were able to have the system
operational and performing microbial
identifications within the six-week time
frame that we needed and we had that
complete csv package
there was no downtime for the customer
and this is extremely important because
it was a very high throughput
thousands of microbial identifications a
week this gave them immediate expansion
of capabilities
so it was so important that this team
came together we worked we executed the
customer was extremely pleased with what
we were able to do daryl it was really a
great experience to work with everybody
in this situation
thank you sandy i am really glad you're
able to share so many customer stories
with us
um so so really what i wanted to really
conclude with
is again in summary um there are really
three main takeaways from our
presentation today that that we can
share and that is
hopefully you you will quickly realize
that thermo fisher scientific offers a
complete solution
including instrumentation assay software
and service and support to facilitate
regulatory compliance for microbial
identification
and
the microsequid system itself offers
high accuracy
of microbial identification for the gmp
environment
and finally you know thermo fisher
scientific
also offers complete csv services to
assist with meeting regulatory
compliance
so with that i want to thank everyone
for their time and attention
uh thank you daryl and sandy for that
very informative presentation
i've been monitoring the chat window
here and i see we've already received
some great questions in the chat window
so i'm just going to go ahead and with
the first question
so first question i already have a 3500
sequencing instrument
what would i need to purchase in order
to have a microseek id
cfv solution specifically would i need
to buy an additional instrument that is
specific for microseek id
yeah thanks man i can actually take that
one um yeah so
you don't need to buy an additional
instrument if you already have a 3500
sequency instrument um pretty much what
you would need to do is is buy the
appropriate msid assays
you'd have to buy the
the associated software and also the csv
service and any other kind of services
that are that are needed so
so the short answer is no you would not
need to buy
a complete new instrument
okay great
all right the next question i saw came
in says thermo fisher scientific has so
many types of sales people and fail
people
who do i contact to find out more about
my particular needs regarding csv
and i also want to know how long it
takes to get validated
you know that's a really great question
ben i'd like to answer that one
we do have a lot of people who
you can contact within our system and
sometimes the best one to contact is
your field application scientist
we can answer a lot of questions about
the amount of time it takes to handle a
csv
because as fas we are on a lot of those
calls
and
we can work with the customer as we um
about details that happen during the csv
process we can also put the customer
into contact with the right person to
get
more information about quotes on the csv
and and what it takes to to make those
things happen
okay well it looks like we're out of
time um as a reminder though to our
audience questions that we didn't have
time for today
and also for any of those questions that
are submitted during the on-demand
period of this webinar after it goes
live to the web those will all be
addressed by the email address that you
provided at the time of registration
um for those
that are attending the live event as
well i want to again remind you um
there's a great opportunity to attend
and ask the expert session
right after uh this call so please um if
your questions weren't answered here
please feel free to attend that ask the
expert session as well
so in summary thank you again to our
speakers daryl leon and sandy true and
to really everyone who participated in
this presentation
we hope you enjoy the rest of the event
and be sure to check back frequently for
new content and presentations added
throughout the year
you